all right
uh so cool to see lots of people I don't
know and I'm honored you want to come
hear me talk
um so hi my name's Carrie and I'm gonna
talk to you today about Mono repos what
they are and how using them had sped up
the pace at which my team and I deliver
better and more secure front-end
applications
um and before I start talking about that
I wanna get an idea of who I'm talking
to here so
quick raise of a hand who's heard of a
monorepo
oh like all of you cool
um
who uses monoreepos
half of you cool
and like who starts to feel their heart
race hand sweat and a feeling of unease
at the pit of your stomach at the idea
of putting code from multiple projects
into a single code base
about just as many as those who use it
cool
um and if that's your reaction
um I totally get it because I was really
skeptical when my charismatic Tech
enthusiastic team lead came and
suggested this approach
I mean it sounds like something that can
quickly become a tightly coupled stack
of cards that will come tumbling down if
you look at it the wrong way or you know
if someone in the neighboring office
sneezes
um and behold the type of system I just
described is
Infamous in our community it is the
feared and dreaded
monolithic
right
um but it doesn't have to be like this
in a moderito and this is one
misconception that I will try to disband
today
so
what is a monorepo a monorepo is a
software development approach where code
for multiple projects or components is
stored in a single Repository
um so let's
for Simplicity say that the opposite of
a monorepo is a poly repo
so with the poly repo strategy
um
you have an app or a project and you
store it in its own repository so
typically a git repository on GitHub or
something like that
um and then if you have some shared
services that are used by more than one
application
um then these each have their own
repository as well and typically you'll
publish them to
npm so they can be shared across
projects
um in comparison in a monorepo they're
all stored in the same Repository
so when you clone your repo you're gonna
get lots of code and not just the code
for your projects
right so as the illustration tries to
show having code organized in a monorepo
doesn't automatically mean that you're
gonna have a typically coupled
architecture or any other architecture
for that matter
you certainly still can and it's
probably a good idea to organize your
code in small independent and
self-contained components with
well-defined boundaries and interfaces
but fundamentally the only difference is
where you put your code
nonetheless the impact of this decision
can be large
um so why would you choose to do this
um instead of splitting it up into
multiple repositories
um I'll get into the general reasons for
why you want to do this but first I want
to give you a quick introduction to our
modern repo
um so our monorepo for front-end apps
came to be as a proof of concept summer
project
in the summer of 2020 four students
created our front-end mode repo to host
three applications and some shared
libraries
to support them
so one of these apps has passed the test
of time and if you're curious about the
sun conditions on a particular property
then you can go to our web shop and
check out our app it's called sulfor
um but anyways today our mono repo has
24 react applications
many of these are demo applications and
internal tools but we also have like a
couple of important ones in there like
with real customers
um and to support this we have 81 shared
libraries
so 81 sounds like a lot
um but many of these are really small so
we have
for example a library for each external
API we call and we have a library just
for dealing with canister IDs
yes they're complicated but I doubts
so the activity and scale of our
monorepo is relatively small
to give you an idea last month we had 26
contributors who
together merged 151 pull requests to the
main branch
and we haven't just put lots of code
into a single repository to manage all
these projects we use a mono repo build
tool called NX
and in addition to code we have some
internal tools developer tools and docs
in our mono repo to help users get going
quickly
um
and finally
our monorepo has one shared CI CD
pipeline to get all these great apps
into production and delivering value to
our customers
so the question is what does monorepo
give us
and why do we choose to organize our
code this way
did you know that Google meta Microsoft
Uber Airbnb and Twitter all employ very
large amount of repos with varying
strategies to scale build systems and
Version Control software with large
volume of code and daily changes
it's true they use one repos
um but the fact that these big
successful companies use monorepose
um of course doesn't mean it's a good
idea for everybody
in fact the chances are high that the
scale and context of your projects are
widely different from theirs
um but it does give an indication at
least that it's not a totally bad idea I
think
so big guys use it bad reason
um but there are some actual benefits of
using monorepose and I'm going to go
through and explain each one of them
um monorepo benefit number one it's
faster to get new projects up and
running
so our mono repo helps us here in two
ways
first we have custom generators
so custom generators in our monorepo
helps us set up new applications with
company specific boilerplate code
for example one of our app generators
will generate code with authentication
and our design system set up and ready
to use
so you run the command
serve up your app and you're good to go
so
you may argue this is not a monorepo
Advantage because there's nothing
stopping you from making templates and
custom generators in its own repo
and it's a good point
however an advantage of having this in a
monorepo setting is
that it's much easier to keep these up
to date as your internal dependencies
evolve
and I'm going to talk more about this
later
so we've got our app created
um
next thing you typically want to do is
get it into production
so when you develop in our mono repo
there's no need to set up your own CI CD
pipeline
no need to configure yaml files and
suffering from the subsequent ppsd you
know post pipeline stress syndrome
each time you want to make an app this
stuff it's set up and ready to use in
our mono repo
um so a bit about how this works uh RCI
CD pipeline looks something like this
each pullover Quest is going to trigger
lint test and build stage of the
pipeline
NX helps us to make sure that we only
run these tasks for projects affected by
the change
moreover NX and NX Cloud will help us
with caching and distribution so it all
runs quite fast
after a merge the pipeline is triggered
again
and again the pipeline will lint test
and build affected projects
if all goes well here we will proceed
and deploy our application to a
development environment
or we the pipeline will do it for you
and if all goes well here we go ahead
and deploy to production
and in addition affected libraries that
are set up to publish to our npm feed
are going to do that
so that users that are outside our
monore repo also can benefit from the
changes
the time it takes to lint test and build
really varies depending on the three
things so how many build agents are
available
how many projects are affected and how
many cache hits do we get
so in the best case when just one
project is affected or every task can
just pull from the cache
it can take three minutes and in the
worst case when 81 lives and 24 apps are
affected by the change
and it's the first time being run it can
take about 35 minutes
but the fun thing though is that because
of remote caching which NX gives us out
of the box
the total time for the merge pipeline
which also includes deployments
is in the same Ridge
um and yeah I know 35 minutes is too
slow but we're gonna make it faster
all right so that's how it works in our
monorepo if you were wondering
but the point is that this is already
set up in our monorepo so teams can
quickly get new apps and changes
deployed without having to configure
yaml Pipelines
next monorepa benefits fewer bugs in
production
so having code in a monorepo such as
ours can help limit bugs that are
allowed to pass into the main branch and
as a result into production
and this is because when all code is in
one place you're immediately going to
get feedback if your changes are
breaking some dependent services
so for example in this situation
if a new feature is needed in the
authentication Library it's easy to
apply the changes locally
and immediately test that it works like
it should on whatever app needs a change
however if the change happens to break
some other app
then this merge will automatically be
blocked by the lint test and build stage
of the pull request pipeline
and when this happens
you can see which command broke the
build and
locally run it and reproduce the error
next monorepo benefits
so monorepose can improve collaboration
and to understand the benefits of a
monorepo for collaboration
it can be useful for us to explore how a
poly repo strategy is
or can be sorry it doesn't have to be
can be harmful to collaboration
so poly repos are really great for
autonomy because it allows teams to
choose their own tools and libraries and
they can decide who what when and how
changes get pushed to production
um it's really super but it comes
because of isolation
and isolation can be harmful for
collaboration
so when working on a project in its own
Repository
I think it can be hard to see the big
picture
I mean the lines in this graph represent
the relationships between the parts of a
system or application
and these lines don't go away just
because code is split into their own
repositors
or maybe sometimes they do
so why why can this happen
well
for one maybe teams know don't know
about a shared service
[Music]
um
maybe the shared service doesn't have a
necessary feature the team needs
um or maybe it's just too much hassle to
integrate with the shared service that
what teams end up doing is copy pasting
code and implementing it themselves
don't judge you've all done this
so in this case you've got the issue of
lots of teams implementing their own
ever Divergence version of the same
thing with varying degrees of quality
wouldn't it be better to do the thing
once and make sure it's done right
in a monorepo it's easy to find shared
modules and examples of their use
because it's all right there in the same
Repository
also it's much easier to see how each
model is connected to each other
and NX even has a tool to draw this
graph for you
as a result shared services become less
of a black box and it becomes easier to
integrate and contribute to these
services
ah
gotcha right
I just said poly repos are more inclined
to have less coupling and monorepose
encourage more coupling
monolith goes go away we gotta talk
about boundaries
so yes monorepose make it easier to
reuse code and inevitably invite
stronger coupling
therefore to achieve the kind of
collaboration that's sustainable in the
long run it's vital to have well-defined
boundaries clear ownership and
delegation of responsibilities
so
let's talk about boundaries
our monorepo management tool again helps
us here
so with NX each Library works like an
API
it's got a public-facing interface which
defines how users are allowed to
interact with the library
then importing and using Code that is
not made available through the public
interface will be prevented by a grumpy
idd IDE and failed linting
and these same mechanisms will also
prevent users from adding circular
dependencies for instance
and with the next you can even add tags
to libraries
um to prevent people from using them at
all so if you add a tag to your library
then only other projects with this tag
are allowed to use Library
yep so that's boundaries
but clear ownership is also really
important so clear ownership is easily
achieved when teams are running their
own repositories
but in a mono repo the lines can appear
more blurred
but I believe it's both important and
possible to keep clear ownership and
responsibility for various services in a
motor repo
and it's simple really if you build it
you own it
and if you break it you fix it
to achieve this in our mono repo we use
Branch policies applied to individual
subfolders of the Repository
so these policies will ensure that all
changes made must be approved by the
responsible team
this way teams have full control of
changes that happen to their code
I believe this encourages loose coupling
and making good abstractions because
teams are going to have to pay the price
of coordinating changes with others as
soon as their change also requires
changes across other projects
next monorepo benefits better internal
dependency management
so a major benefits of using a monorepo
is that it really simplifies the
management of internal dependencies
so when I say internal dependencies I
mean the libraries that we make
ourselves
so not the external npm packages we
download into our
applications
there's our
separated from our application code but
the apps depend on them to rip so for
example
your authentication libraries and the
components of your design system
and having all these in the morning repo
means that we have a single source of
Truth
there's only one true version of our
internal dependencies and that is the
one running in the main branch
as a result
you don't have to deal with juggling
versions
and ending up in the dreaded state of
dependency hell
so you know when you depend on a package
that depends on a specific version of
another package but then like another
package you use depends on the version
that's incompatible with that other
package that the other package needed
and then your like console goes well I
can't resolve your dependencies and I'm
not going to let you build your app blah
blah etc etc
dependency Health yeah
if all your internal dependencies are in
the same repo then at any point in time
there's only going to be one version of
each dependencies and
these will be perfectly compatible
yay no dependency hell
so the next benefit of monorepose
better internal external dependency
management
um so there's a question mark here
because
while there are many benefits to
external dependency Management in a
motor repo this is probably the most
challenging thing we deal with
so by external dependencies I'm talking
about those dependencies that are not
made by us in our case the mpm packages
we install in our Repository
for example react or material UI
our monorepo has a single package Json
file to manage external dependencies
and that means that all projects in the
monorepo have the same version of each
external dependency
oh man
this guy just came back again
so with external dependencies we don't
have the source code in our monore repo
which makes sense because we're not
maintaining these patchy packages
but it does mean that for these
dependencies we need to manage versions
and managing and updating external
dependencies can be a real chore I mean
it's something you just have to do right
and the effects aren't even visible
and working on it will prevent you from
making features and developing your apps
also dependency health
not fun
so managing external dependencies in a
mono repo is not easier
in fact it's probably harder because you
got more projects that need to work with
the updates and
well you probably have more dependencies
you have to deal with
so since major external dependencies
upgrades are possibly the largest pain
points in working with the monorepo
here's a tip from me that's helped us so
try to do the upgrade without upgrading
makes sense for it
quite scenery right
um so what do I mean well when working
in a monorepo with lots of activity you
really want to avoid having one
ginormous pull request
because with all the necessary changes
Because by the time you get it working
and all the teams have approved the
change
um your main branch is going to have
moves on and it's going to be impossible
to merge these changes
so for example when we upgraded from
react 17 to react 18. most of the
necessary changes for things to work in
react 18 also worked in react 17.
even though they weren't mandatory here
so what we did was
we locally upgraded to react 18 and so
that all the apps were breaking
um and then we put in the work and got
one single App working with react to 18.
then
since these changes were compatible with
react 17 we could merge the code changes
while
um not yet doing the react 18 upgrade
so we repeated this until all apps were
compatible with react 18.
and that way we could make the upgrades
in many small steps and on a per app
basis
so that when the time came to actually
make the job jump it wasn't such a big
deal
uh and of course every upgrade is
different and this is not always going
to be possible
um so you're gonna have to adapt
another example of a larger upgrade was
react router so
same same a little bit different
um react router was actually pretty
smooth because they provided a
compatibility package which could run
alongside the old version
so with this upgrade you could gradually
migrate apps to the compatibility
package
um
and then again
when it came time to make the job actual
upgrade it was trivial
so yeah external dependency measurements
in a large repo is harder than in a
small repo with less code
that's obvious
but nonetheless there are several
advantages of having to do this
um
First Advantage is you really quickly
and easily get an overview of your
external dependencies
and this is great when you want to check
for if you're following open source
policies or when the security people
come asking you questions
um if you do have a vulnerable package
that you discover
well then you only need to patch it one
place and there's a single pipeline
that's going to roll out this patch to
all your apps
next advantage of this way of working is
We're In It Together right so
when working in a motor vehicle like
ours you're gonna have lots more people
interested in the health of your repo
and making sure it stays up to date
and during a more significant upgrade
you're going to have more projects and
more people in a similar situation
most likely with similar issues so
instead of everyone struggling alone in
their own lonely repositories we can
face these challenges together
and I find it easier to give and receive
help when people understand your context
and when you have an abundance of
examples and you can quickly reproduce
issues
so next benefits of this method of
external dependency management is
when you're working on a long large
important and heavily used repository
then automating your dependency
management as much as possible is going
to give you
much greater gains than if you did it in
a smaller repo that only your team cares
about
and automating stuff is fun
so for example
um we've made a script that uses nx's
dependency graph to list unused
dependencies so we can delete them
and by applying automation we can make
sure that upgrades have been more
frequently meaning that we take smaller
steps at a time
and upgrades become less of a big deal
and finally despite individual upgrades
being more work in a mono repo than with
the polar repo I do believe that the
cumulative time that would have been
spent
and the number of people having to be
involved is probably less in a motor
repo than with a poly repo strategy
so next benefits another nice effect of
having all your code in one place is
that making changes and Bug fixes to
libraries and getting them rolled out to
all your apps becomes really easy
so for example say we want to do
something small like
total company Rebrand
now I found this old logo which I quite
like
how will we go about changing this logo
Operation new logo
so first how would this look in a poly
repo strategy
well it's not too complicated right
you're gonna go find your logo library
in its logo repository and make the
necessary code changes I don't know
change the SVG file or something like
that
um then you're going to want to publish
uh your changes however this works so
let's say you have CI CDs set up and
you merge the changes and your package
gets published
next you need to broadcast all the teams
about this really cool new feature that
they need to integrate into their
projects
so for each project that uses the logo
Library
whenever the responsible team has the
time
they have to go and upgrade the library
check everything looks so okay and
hopefully you know it fits with the
other dependencies they have
um and they want to then publish uh
their app with the upgrade
yep and how long this will take in a
poly repo strategy is really hard to say
for two reasons so
firstly there's a for Loop here of
potentially unknown length
and we need to know which repository
needs to apply the changes and which
team is responsible
also this whole process is asynchronous
so Tim's needs to prioritize making the
change and we'll do it when they get the
time
oh and plot twists what if team X like a
week later discovers a bug or breaking
change in the upgraded logo Library
well we got to start the whole process
over again
in comparison how would this look in a
monorepo well
it's easy so Step One is the same
except we don't have to go looking for
the code and some other Repository
and we can immediately see the impact of
the change on all dependent projects
then when we're happy with the changes
we'll make a pull request and merge them
this will trigger our CI CD pipeline
that will deploy changes to production
for all affected applications which is
going to be most of them in this case
right and that's it
in total we can get the change out to
all apps in one to two hours
and just give me a sec let me clean up
here
right that's better
so
the point of this example is to
illustrate that money repos make it much
easier to make changes to your internal
dependencies
and why is that well
firstly there's a lot fewer steps
also
when making changes in a mono repo you
can immediately see the effects that
your change will have on all its
dependent projects
so tests in your own and other projects
will hopefully uncover if you've made
some breaking changes
and you're able to spin up all these
applications and see how the change will
look
third Advantage is it's much faster so
changes get applied to all affected
projects immediately no for Loop no
async business
which brings me to the next advantage of
the monorepo strategy so the team
responsible for the logo Library didn't
need to communicate or coordinate with
any other team to get their changes
applied
team autonomy for the win right
yeah
so
on the other hand the nice thing about a
poly repo strategy is that teams have
full control of how and when they apply
the change
and you could argue that for something
as impactful as a logo change maybe you
want that
so
okay but you have options in a mono repo
here so
one thing you could do is versioning and
I know it sounds hypocritical given my
whole points about Mono repos being
single version
um but it's an option so in this
scenario you'd make a new library
call it I don't know new logo OR Logo
and teams can start using this whenever
they're ready
and since all projects are in your model
repo you still have full control of
which projects are still using the old
one and you can start chasing down
people when they haven't migrated yet
finally
um when everyone's over you can delete
the old logo Library
another option is to use a feature
toggle
so lots of ways this can be implemented
but
one way is that you'll implement the
logo library in such a way that the old
logo sorry the new logo just shows up in
your development and local environments
but then the old logo is still showing
in production
this way teams can opt in to have the
new logo shown in production
when they're ready
um and the final option is you could
communicate
so simply apply the changes and ask
teams to spin up the app and verify that
it's okay to merge
and if your monorepo small this can also
work
so logo library and updating logo it's a
silly example but
now imagine that instead of updating a
logo
the change you want to make is to patch
a known vulnerability in some external
dependency
so in this scenario being able to move
really fast and not involving too many
people is a huge advantage
another change you might want to make is
to move your apps to a new hosting
platform
so question has anyone here been part of
a mess migration to the cloud
oh just me
a couple okay well we have in fact one
of the first things I did in my
professional career was to migrate about
30 back-end services
manly.net apis from running on-prem to
being hosted in the cloud
and this meant going into 30 different
repositories with 30 slightly different
pipelines and
versions of dependencies and making the
necessary upgrades and changes
it took us months and it wasn't just my
team doing this
so in our mono repo we've got one single
Pipeline and a standardized way of
deploying and building our apps
and as a result we can experiment with
different hosting platforms
and if we get it working for one chances
are high it's gonna work for all of them
with minimal to no involvement from
other teams
mono repo benefits number seven old code
gets maintained
so just by being in a mono repo old code
is gonna get maintained
all the projects that aren't actively
being worked on will automatically and
continuously get updates and changes
applied to them so for example your logo
updates critical bug fixes and external
dependency upgrades
um it doesn't come for free though so
especially when it comes to updating
external dependencies with breaking
changes
project owners they're gonna need to
confront their old code make adjustments
and verify changes
and this Forces teams to continuously
consider if the project is important
enough to keep around
and if the answer is no well then code
will get removed from the main branch
and forever live on in git memory
and we call this process graveyarding
so the continuous maintenance and
deletion of unnecessary code
I find is really useful for preventing
the buildup of technical debt
and then another monorepo benefits is
standardization
so standardization helps to reduce
cognitive load and make Services scale
better
so rcto
hey Maurice
he's back here uh he recently showed us
this analogy relating to standardization
and scaling
so he said pets don't scale because when
you need to treat every case or service
individually it's going to consume so
much more time and effort if you
standardize and treat your services more
like cattle
um Foursquare and humble and Kim write
in their book accelerates that
there's a place for standardization
particularly around architecture and
configuration of infrastructure
so this is what we tried to do
um we standardize our deployment
pipeline which I've already talked about
um
which means again teams can practice
continuous delivery out of the box don't
have to configure their own yaml
Pipelines
and despite the shared pipeline
um
teams can deploy their things relatively
independently or at least independent of
unrelated services with the help of NX
um
so here's another quote of a quote that
I also read in accelerate
um debugging problems with someone
else's code gets a lot harder and is
basically impossible unless there is a
universal standard way to run every
service in a debuggable sandbox
so we have this in our motor repo we
have a debuggable sound box and it's
called localhost
so projects in our model repo they all
have the same bundler linter and test
Runner which makes it really easy for
anyone to spin up any project
and debug issues through multiple
services at the same time
yeah so those were the benefits of using
a mono repo
let's talk about the bad stuff
like what can go wrong in a mono repo
what could possibly go wrong if you put
all your eggs in one basket
truth is lots of stuff can go wrong
um so one thing is broken main branch
a broken main branch is when some bugs
some place has been allowed to get
merged
uh into the main branch and this can
cause apps to break or it can block
continuous delivery and block people
from getting their changes out
um it's always a risk and it's bad when
it happens in the small repo but worse
when it happens in a mono repo because
well you can take down all your stuff
that sucks
right so story time
not too long ago I was working on our
monorepo Pipeline and migrating it from
Windows build agents to running on
Ubuntu the legends
um I'd gotten it all working and even
tested deploying one of the less
important apps to the dev environments
and saw that everything rendered okay
so all seemed to find and I was really
excited because everything seemed much
quicker on the Ubuntu agents
so after review from a teammate with a
comment I trust you on this one
I mean how is he supposed to verify it
anyways
uh we merge the changes and apps got
deployed
so 20 minutes later I hear from another
teammates that our apps or one of our
apps is not working
and we'll scramble and discover that
none of the monorepo apps are getting
any of their environment variables
panic button time
um so we need to roll back
and how did we do this
well
first we have to go and look at our
pipeline runs and find a pipeline run
that rolled out all the applications
so that we could rerun this and
come back to a working state
next we had to monitor our Pipeline and
cancel all new pipeline runs to prevent
rolling out the bug again
simultaneously we wanted to revert the
bad commit that caused the bug
and when this was done we could turn the
pipelag back on and apologize very
sincerely to everybody
and also learn from what happened
so the consequence of this was 50
minutes of a broken main where people
can push changes to their apps
um
and a bunch of broken apps so at this
point we're pretty happy that we only
have a couple of important apps in our
mod repo
um
but also as a result we applied some
measures so after this happened we added
end-to-end tests to ensure that we do in
fact get environment variables
and we made some measures to make it
easier to roll back all apps so for
example we want to have nightly builds
so we have checkpoints where we can
easily find a pipeline to roll back to
and a bunch more stuff
but the point is if you're gonna put all
your eggs in one basket
it's really worth investing in building
a good solid and rugged baskets and to
have a repair kit ready for if it does
break if you get my analogy
so another mono repo risk is slow builds
and this can happen
but luckily when working locally with an
ex or with any with modern repo build
tools like an X you will only ever be
building projects needed to run your app
and when it comes to the pipeline NX
also helps us with making sure that only
affected projects get built and tested
moreover they allow you to distribute
these task running to multiple machines
and provide remote caching so
I think slow builds don't need to be an
issue
another objection I've heard using
monorepose is that when repositories get
too large get get operations like
cloning and blame can get really slow
so Google have even made their own
version control system to deal with
their enormous Repository
honestly at this point I don't have a
really good answer to this I'm not sure
at exactly what points a repository
becomes too big forget to handle
um however at our current scale it
really hasn't been an issue and from my
limited research there are many things
we can do to prevent this
and I believe we have quite some time to
figure it out
um next risk
bugs can roll out to unknowing app
owners
so remember with our current monorepo
setup if changes are made to core
Library this is going to trigger builds
and releases of all affected projects
and if the change doesn't alter the
public interface then this can happen
without affected projects being evolved
um so yes this means bugs can roll out
to apps but the upside is teams can work
autonomously
and you also get the bug fixes for free
and you can reduce the risk of other
teams introducing bugs to your app by
writing
good tests and testing these assumptions
you have to other services
next monorepo risk is less Freedom so
when using a mono repo there will likely
be less freedom
so using mono repo will force teams to
use certain tools for example when using
our mono repo you have to use NX
typescript and react
also you can't deploy your services
completely independently
so if you change your service all its
independent all its dependent services
are going to be built tested and
deployed
uh and this might be annoying if you
just want to change a small thing in
your app and don't want to be bothered
by other people's stupid code
um but I would argue that it's a small
price to pay because as I mentioned
earlier this will prevent bugs from
getting deployed to production
um also
as a code owner in the motor repo you
have to update on someone else's
schedule
so for a motor vehicle strategy to be
successful
updates they have to be frequent and
small which means app owners can't delay
upgrades to more suitable time
the advantage though is that you do get
a lot of supports and some minor
upgrades for free
um yeah but in the end of the day less
freedom is a trade-off for
standardization and scale
and final monorepo risk is
messy unmaintainable code
so the monolith ghost is always lurking
when you put code in one place and make
it really easy to share
there's always a risk of things getting
complicated
so there's a trade-off between not
repeating yourself and increased
coupling that
um you're going to have to monitor and
it's going to need constant care to
prevent this from happening
so
let's conclude how has mono repos made
us faster better and safer
using a monorepo has made it easier to
create new apps and shared libraries
because of custom generators and that
create the necessary boilerplate code
for us
and because of a shared pipeline for
continuous delivery already being set up
and ready to use
it's also given us a shortened feedback
loop for changes so you can easily and
quickly
get changes deployed to multiple apps
remember no for Loop and no async
business
also mono repo saves its time by
eliminating the need to manage versions
of our internal dependencies
how they made us better
well using a mono repo means continuous
deployments sorry continuous
improvements are being made so in the
entire portfolio
even the projects that aren't actively
being developed
using a monorepo improves collaboration
by improving visibility of shared
services and increasing the ease of
integrating with them
which means that we can make more shared
services and can invest in making high
quality services instead of having teams
Implement their own versions with vary
degrees of quality
how has monorepo improved security
well by using a monorepo we ensure that
all code gets maintained and patched and
this prevents services from being
forgotten and falling behind on
important security updates and patches
in addition our mono repo has defined
decommissioning process which ensures
that unused or unimportant apps
and projects will get deleted
moreover our monorepo enforces good
continuous delivery practices out of the
books and this ensures that code must
pass automated tests before being
allowed into production and gives a
standardized way to quickly roll back
apps if they should be necessary
furthermore by having a shared set of
dependencies
you really quickly get and easily get an
overview
in other words we've got all the bad
practices in one place
which means this really simplifies any
review process and makes it easier to
enforce policies
for example relating to the use of
external dependencies
so that if a vulnerability is discovered
at some point this can quickly be
patched in multiple projects with a
single commit
so
should you use a monorepo
all right that's cool to hear we have a
yes over here
so for us in our situation and at our
scale we've had lots of benefits of
monoreepos
of our money repo strategy but our mono
repo is Tiny and has a relatively small
number of contributors
and as I hope I've managed to
communicate there are some nuts and
significant challenges that you have to
deal with if you choose this approach
and these just get bigger as your
monorepo scales
so it's continuous work and requires a
strong collaborative culture to keep it
working smoothly smoothly and growing
dynamically
so I would say monorepo can be good but
other strategies are not wrong
and in the end of the day it's maybe how
you choose to collaborate and how you
architect your Solutions
that's going to be more important than
where you store your code
so that's all I had for you today
um thanks so much for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
oh we've got questions cool yes
um I don't think I want to do that on
the spot
um but is there something in particular
you're wondering about
yeah so we're actually in azure devops
um and we have a dedicated team that
maintains these build agents for us
um so all I know is there are Ubuntu
agents and they work for us
um yep it works on Windows and we have
developers who work on Windows or on Mac
or on Linux
so it works but it's
seems to me that
like Annex at least was made for Windows
last and it works a bit better on yeah
you're Ubuntu and your Mac OS
did that answer your question yeah
yes
26.
yeah
yeah sure sure so
um
my team where there's six of us
and we probably own like
80 of the code in the mono repo so
we've got most of the core tools
[Music]
um
and we've been like playing in there on
our own for a couple years and just
recently started getting people from the
outside inside
um and yeah so we people from outside
our team now we have a design system
which is a separate group of people
and then we have some new apps coming in
um
yep but it really helps that my team
have been in there for a while we've
been able to experiment and
also we can do the grunt work of the
upgrades get all the core Services
working before we start bothering other
people with updating their things
um so that's how it is right now but of
course this is not going to scale
um we can't do all the things
and yeah just maintaining and
coordinating this monorepo is
yep gonna need more and more work as
this thing skills
um but that's where we are right now
yeah and you maybe saw we do publish
some stuff to npm
so I mean our company has been around
for 60 years and we've got lots of apps
uh so
yeah not all apps are getting into the
monorepo at one time and but we want
people to be able to use the design
system and these things
um so that's kind of
a compromise I guess
um
but it works
works okay
um the only problem is many times we've
ended up breaking things for people
outside the monorepo and then
well you don't really find out before
someone comes and tells you so
yes
oh to have more of your SEC
um
yeah
um so we haven't chosen to do that
currently at our company because like
anything you want to do things gradually
uh
I think but in my private monorepo
um
everyone's got a private one repo right
um well then I have also my C sharp so I
make my my front end in
reacts and then I have some C sharp
function function apps that I put in
there as well
um and then deploy them to Azure static
web app
um with kind of the same thing so
I get Advantage from this because I can
update my back end and my front end in
the same commit
and don't have to do this whole game
with making it backwards compatible and
you know back and forth
so I don't know would I advise jumping
right into that in an established
company maybe not
but if you're small and starting out
sure try it and uh
I'm in as they say
it's never too late to change your mind
um
um so we deployed to production every
time
changes emerge to the main branch
so with the last month I guess 151 times
uh and then well if you multiply it on
all the apps then it's much more
so we're continuously deploying to
production yeah
yeah
so uh our build monorepo management tool
NX takes care of all of this for us
um so we can
yeah we can for example write
a command that says NX affected graph
and it will spin up a graph and
oh wait and I will list all the affected
projects uh and make sure this all works
yeah
onboarding new people someone's nodding
over here so it's a colleague of mine
um
yeah that's that is the goal right the
whole reason we want to have a mono repo
is to make the developer experience
easier to make it easier to you know do
authentication the Northcutt way to
yeah do all these
true
well there's a lot you could know
um but really you don't have to know
much about NX for example to get going
so we have a short readme I think
yeah it's maybe an A4 page of how you
set up and
get your permissions for things and
clone the repo and run your first step
so
no I don't think it's too difficult to
get going yeah yes
oh yeah all the time
um but this is not a problem because
well people are working of different
parts of the system right so
um yeah people are working their apps
their Libs
um
so you're not
except for when you do these big
refactorings or big upgrades you're not
really treading on each other so
it works quite well yep
um
no we don't do that uh but that's
something we have in our backlog to look
into
or at least we want to make it clear to
whoever's making this pull request that
their change is affecting all of these
projects
um so no we don't currently do that but
something like that or being able to get
notified when someone does this is
something we want to look into
yes
um well actually we're in the luxurious
situation that my team has like 80 of
all the projects
so
I mean for us it worked great
um but what we we really do try to take
other teams into account and we know
people have
you know their deadlines and things
they're working on so we want to make it
as easy as possible for them to go in
and do the changes by
and also giving people enough warning
and uh
so a few people and so far not so much
problems uh yes
oh absolutely so you know as soon as you
get more than two or three teams working
this thing becomes its own platform
um which means dedicated people to
keep it working and yeah prevent it from
getting out of control
um
so that is the direction we're going in
that's more questions
yeah yeah
so no we don't have a smart way of doing
this
um well one thing we do we have this
graveyarding process
um
so if one project is being extra
difficult
um we can leave it behind that's kind of
like the only way to go your monorepo
goes forward and yeah if you're gonna be
in there you got to keep up
so if we remove you from the main branch
we don't have to delete uh your service
immediately
which means okay you have time to get
back in there and get your upgrade so
that's
yeah we try to avoid it but that is one
one way you could do it
okay last question I think is my time's
up yeah
hold you know in the longer run is a
bigger
teams and still still using one over
um I hope so I mean we're gonna try and
and you want to always look ahead and
see what rates risks are coming
um what can happen when your monorepo
skills so
I have no idea but we're gonna try our
best yeah
okay
uh totally yeah so all of a sudden
there's other people in there and then
you get really embarrassed because
you're still in react 17 for example
uh and it kind of
no judgments if you're still on react 17
but uh yeah it kind of gives you a push
to like
yeah to keep your house in order really
it's like having guests you want them to
feel welcome yeah
okay
um feel free to come and talk to me
after uh that was my time yeah
[Applause]